into washington we go where the labor
department has just released a stunning
new inflation report the consumer price
index in march was eight and a half
percent higher than it was just a year
ago and that is by far the highest rate
of inflation
since 1981. ed o'keefe is at the white
house for us where officials did say to
expect this but it's still shocking to
see ed good morning
well that's right tony the white house
had warned the numbers would be quote
extraordinarily elevated and they sure
are repeating that top line number 8.5
percent overall inflation jump versus a
year ago food prices jumped 8.8
energy prices spiked 32 percent these
latest figures account for the month of
march the first full month since the war
in ukraine began and gas prices started
spiking nationwide and around much of
the world the white house has said that
these price spikes are due to what they
call putin's price spike but remember
most of them had actually started
climbing well before the war began and
even before these new numbers came out
cbs news polling showed nearly 70
percent of americans disapprove of
president biden's handling of inflation
and 66 say the higher prices have been
difficult or a hardship so as the
president heads to iowa today the white
house is expected to unveil a new
attempt at helping drive down gas prices
the epa is going to allow the sale of
special gas blends that is fuel mixed
with 15 ethanol it's known as e-15 and
isn't normally sold during warmer months
because of concerns of high gas
emissions but it'll be a really big deal
in iowa which of course is the nation's
largest biggest ethanol producing state
the president's headed to a
congressional district represented by
democrat cindy axne one of those facing
a tough reelection fight this year
election day is just 209 days away
thank you very much